Ezekiel Elliott the Dallas Cowboys
running back who has had his issues off
the field over the year was handcuffed
at 3 a.m. in the parking lot of in EDM
festival called The Electric Daisy
Carnival in Las Vegas he was appeared to
be arguing with his girlfriend and a
security guard said something to him and
Zeke kind of backed him down you know
and got in his face and then gave him a
little forearm shiver and the guy went
flying into into some into some gates
there but they're not gonna press
charges not arrested nothing really
happened in the end yeah the guy was
like oh that's CG Elliott you know what
we can settle this between ourselves yes
meaning cash money exchanged hands my
favorite part of this story and listen
Zeke didn't he wasn't it wasn't like
fighting he was arguing with his
girlfriend didn't never hit her I was
like blocking her path security was
right to intervene I don't know what
they said to him maybe he was right to
shove the guy to the ground I feel like
if you're as DQ Elliot throw people to
the ground you know I mean I bet if he
was like I could punch anyone he would
hit that security guard anyone in the
world is just like I even a little a
little forearm but you know he
immediately is wrong but my favorite
quote from the article is this he was
cuffed as a precautionary measure
he was released with no charges he left
to Vegas that night and went to his
youth football camp in Dallas on Sunday
the fact that he took a break from his
youth football camp to go to a to go to
a the electric daisy carnival and beat
up a security guard and then go back to
his youth football camp in Dallas
like imagine what that was like on
Sunday for all those kids to be like hey
congratulations on not getting going to
jail for assaulting a security guard
that's the NFL yeah you know I went
after I saw that detail I did go look
for any of the media coverage of the
youth football camp and there was some
but none of them seemed to mention the
what happened the night before he
certainly you know did not address it
with the count the campers or anything
like that
you think that he gave them a message of
you know no matter what your obstacles
are you got to work hard at whatever
you're doing whether it's doing the
dishes or doing your running for
football you got to work hard
what was what was he originally
suspended for it last year he was
suspended for domestic violence yeah so
if it isn't if your if your partner's in
front of you and you got to get through
him
don't let that stand in your way I think
that do you think of Zuko Elliott really
cares about kids or you think he's doing
this as a kind of a PR move like if you
get arrested for domestic violence or I
get suspended for domestic violence do
you have to then open up a youth camp
know teach kids a lot of a lot of
players have these youth camps and some
are more invested than others in them
some there was like these really great
camps some it's like these one-day
things where the payers I don't know
what the arrangement is but the players
involvement is you know relatively
minimal that said you know the kids
freakin love it so it's hard to kill
them no matter what the motivation is
but it is a strange subculture because
Tyreke Hill had a youth camp scheduled
for I think this month and then just you
know very quietly it was announced
that's it was now gonna be the Sammy
Watkins youth camp instead of the Tyree
kill youth camp they just sort of took
his name off of it and put a different
Chiefs player on it which I think was
the right move you know maybe I mean I
just think that I'm just glad to hear
that Zeek Elliot is Zeek is really into
this you know and not just doing it for
PR he's like really his heart is in this
he's like a new he's like the new Jerry
Sandusky multiple Brazilian news
networks reported that a 15 year old boy
went to jail after he successfully
catfished a pedophile on tinder by
posing as a 14 year old girl having
these this back and forth with this
elderly man who was a better pedophile
meeting the man at a park and then
beating the out of him while
dressed as spider-man mm-hmm head to toe
in spider gear what I love about this
story is that a 15 year old posing as a
fort
year old it's clear any like see saved
all the texts and everything like all
the text between them and then kept it
in Drive so that when they came to the
park to arrest him for beating up an old
man he was like no look read this I
don't think they even arrested the old
man they were just like okay like no one
knows what happened to either spider-man
or the old man but it sounds to me like
a 15 year old kid just really wanted to
beat up an old man just really want to
be like how can I get an old man to come
meet me as posing as a 14 year old girl
and collect all this info so I don't get
in trouble and then I'm gonna kick an
old man's ass dressed up like my
favorite comic book character or yeah or
he's trying to you know be a superhero I
mean this is some superhero listen
I've seen I shouldn't put him in jail I
know a lot about spider-man he's never
once catfished anyone to go beat them up
even though spider-man is beating up
several old men well some of the vulture
is like an old guy in the comics he some
of the details were a little different
because he came there with two pocket
knives two retractable Tonka's yeah
which are which are there was kind of
billy club type thing yeah like you like
like it's almost you like do you like a
whip thing and then like a it's like
it's basically a martial arts billy club
type of thing and then some bladed brass
knuckles mm-hmm only like 15 and 14 year
olds have bladed Bratz black necklace
that's true
but imagine like you have those you just
like what am i doing with these I got
nothing to do with them I can't hit a
normal person but I could beat up in an
elderly man with them let me try to find
a pedophile like if you really just want
to go kick someone's ass and you'd like
you want to practice before I get like
if I wanted to practice before I punch
your dad and like you can beat up any
pedophile and no one would ever get mad
like no one would be mad at you so I
think this is hilarious and the fact the
cops were still like wait you did what
right they had to take that he kept all
the exchange between the two on his
flash drive and he brought that with him
and then he called the police himself
mm-hmm because I think you know he
wanted this to become a big time story
or maybe he saw like a future where
there's like the opposite of Jail where
if you do something bad a freedom no
where you do something badass like like
break out some brass knuckles
against pedophiles then they put you in
like a really nice place where they take
care of your your
food and it's like a basically like a
nice hook Hospital yeah like a nice
hotel where they take care of your food
and like okay you're sentenced to that
for two years cuz you were such a badass
then why just up like spider-man clearly
he like really wanted to dress up like
spider-man and he's weapons on an old
man and and found a way to do it that I
applaud this fifteen-year-old boy if you
were the old man or you got a nice
Waterman if I was if I were the actor
who plays spider-man now I forget his
name do you know what I'm talking about
Tom Holland yes if I were Tom Holland
I'd be shakin in my boots thinking about
this fifteen-year-old kid who could
replace me at any time with brass now
imagine how badass spider-man would be
with RIT with a brass knuckles with
razors on them and who solely beat up
old men old men pedophiles I would watch
that movie
that'd be like Jon McClure you tell me
you like you send you send this the
little kid spider-man after Z Kelley
he's not gonna be in the news anymore
he's gonna be scared straight secret
yeah
I'm sayin like you can have this guy
take care of different crimes would
Zeke's not gonna do anything with this
kid I'm saying 15 your boy it's not
Zeke's girlfriend
[Music]
you